i was on the phone with my son the other
day i would never put you on the spot i
said to my son what does wild success
look like look like for you this year
and he was like you know playoffs and i
was like listen that's a pipe dream for
me wild success is
improvement and the thing that i really
appreciate about you as a general
manager is that you have put
an amazing team around
zach and you know we're going to see if
zack's going to become the man we hope
he's going to become but for the first
time in a long time as a fan
i genuinely feel like you have given him
all the tools he needs
i mean you can't do any much more than
you've done and and we appreciate it as
fans we appreciate it you hit nail ahead
i mean improvement and i feel like we've
seen that the first the first week plus
um
throughout the entire team not just the
quarterback but throughout the entire
team so
that's a one of coach styles big things
is hey just go to bed better than when
you woke up this morning just
that one percent you do it in
and i know people kind of roll their
eyes and oh cliche but it's real like we
just we just got to keep stacking good
days together get better stay healthy
and uh
there will be improvement right is that
a lot of pressure to put on a young kid
or just is that just that's what if
you're going to be an nfl quarterback
you know you're the lead singer in the
band that's you that's what comes with
the job it comes with the territory you
know i think and that's a great thing
about about zach is uh you know he
doesn't back down from that that that
pressure he knows i feel like he he gets
it he understands um
what's expected of him as an nfl
starting nfl quarterback and he embraces
it gary mentioned the expectations real
quick like is there a number a win total
that you maybe set for yourself that you
would like to see this team achieve to
fulfill all of these expectations you
have for the club well yeah i mean i
think it kind of goes back to what gary
and i were just talking about um it's
just it's improvement you know we've got
to be better than we were last year and
you know i think you know that last year
the last couple years haven't been good
enough and you know we've uh we've got
it we've got a great great group of uh
people assembled and they're they're
really busting their butts every day and
i hope you guys stick around and uh and
watch you know because these guys are
really put in a ton of work and
um it's improvement it's that's
right gary said it and yeah right on
point i'll take the i'll take the losses
as long as the losses are like you know
even if the losses start to to mount up
to more than i thought if they're
overtime losses if they're last second
losses if there's like oh my god if this
would have gone that way kind of losses
those you can live with it's you know
the blowouts or or or the ones where the
team shoots himself in the foot so
that's i'm looking for the close games
and just be competitive yeah tough
discipline competitive and i think you
know we've got one one of the things you
should you guys should watch a day of
practice i mean we've got a uh we're
expecting to play in a lot more close
games this year and it's going to come
down to special teams and kicking and
we've got a great kicking competition
going on between eddie pinero and greg
zurline and so um you know we're we're
expecting whoever wins that you know
to really help us this year wise man
once said don't take the foot out of
football no and it's important